hi everyone my name is Brian Buckland
and I'm from IBM cloud today we're going
to be talking about multi-tenancy
multi-tenancy in the cloud means using
shared services and resources for
multiple clients these resources can
include compute networking and storage
each tenants data is isolated and is
invisible to other tenants you might ask
why I have an apartment building here
the apartment building provides a good
example of what a multi-tenancy
is each tenant has their own key each
tenant can come and go into their
apartment as they please and they can
add and remove items to their apartment
as long as they're following the
building guidelines and regulations so
all the tenants of the building can
access the building but they can't they
can only access their own apartment so
therefore all the other apartments are
secured because you can only access your
own a tenant may invite somebody from
the outside world
to their apartment as an authorized
person but by default each apartment is
secured and locked down so the building
the building is providing us with shared
resources they shared resources can
include for an example water and
electricity these shared resources are
available to the whole building and as a
tenant of this building we can choose
how much or how little of these shared
resources we wish to use the apartment
building will meter your usage of these
resources and there we have a
multi-tenancy using our shared resources
this isn't a good example and
relationship to what we have over here
in the cloud environment each tenant can
have as small or as big allocations of
compute network and storage is really up
to the end-user how big or how small
they want their environment to summarize
just to some of the benefits to
multi-tenancy
include scalability
we can also have lower entry cost so
lower entry costs is you know you can
start small and you can grow the last
one I put up there let me write this one
out is cloud maintains maintains these
shared resources so they will manage to
compute the network and the storage and
make sure there's always ample available
for you to utilize thank you for
watching this video if you have any
questions or comment please drop us a
line below want to see more videos like
this in the future be sure to LIKE and
subscribe please do not forget you can
always get started in the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IBM cloud
account